m
[Silence]
I
Zu
[Silence]
We are continuing in
our description and
explanation of many of the most
prominent Miracles performed by Allah
subhanahu waala for the prophet Muhammad
s many of these Miracles are mentioned
in the Quran the Quran itself being the
chief of these
Miracles of course this is in
addition to what is in which we have
mentioned this book that we're reading
from as we
mention each week just as a reminder
this book that we are reading
from for Ani this is one of the
references
used
by is one of the books that he drew from
in
authoring and
so the Miracles of the Prophet s.
wasam are in inedibly important for us
to
know we cannot know all of them they
are far too
numerous some of them very nuanced
others very
prominent all of them
irrefutable these Miracles were given to
the prophet Sall alai wasam performed by
Allah through him in order that his
prophethood be
verified that it be confirmed by Allah
subhanahu wa taala this is the only way
that a person can truly
know or this is the main way that every
all of the common folk and everyone
can look for themselves and
see that
this person truly is a prophet a
messenger of Allah every Prophet every
messenger was given Miracles which they
were able to perform by Allah's will
pertinent to the time and place and
people in order to prove the validity of
his
prophethood Allah subhah Waal
says indeed we have sent our Messengers
with clear evidences these clear evid
evidences are miracles in and Muslim Abu
narrates that the prophet
Sall
[Silence]
saidar Muslim Abu narrates that the
prophet
said there has never been sent a prophet
before me except that he was given
Miracles that he could perform
irrefutable Miracles so compelling the
likes of which people will
believe upon witnessing them upon
experiencing them upon seeing them the
prophets and Messengers have been given
these Miracles and this is one of the
most distinguishing features
between true prophets and false prophets
true prophets and false prophets we've
discussed this very
thoroughly but there is a point that we
have to make and that
is the issue of
belief
Islam is logical for that of which can
be understood by the human
mind it makes perfect sense it fits
together
perfectly it is
fluid and able to be adapted by any
place or time or
people however the believer once they
enter into Islam once a person
says
at this point they are
following the prophet
s they are adhering to all that which he
brings which means that not every single
thing that he says not every single
thing we find in the
Quran every single one of us will
specifically understand it or understand
the wisdom behind it
and we don't have to know how something
works in order to be for it to be of
benefit to us most of the things that we
use every day in our lives we don't know
how they work we trust in
them our world is based on that it's
built on
that and very much in the same way when
we believe in the messenger of Allah
Muhammad s. wasam we accept what he
says whether we understand it or not
understanding it is not a prerequisite
of
adherence
understanding is a prerequisite of
knowledge it's a prerequisite of
Enlightenment but it is not a
prerequisite of adherence we adhere to
what Allah says to what the messenger
says
s whether we indiv visually understand
it or
not
and this takes humility and this takes
strict adherence this is why Allah
subhanahu Waal began his book by
mentioning this
point he says
subhah he says that this book the Quran
there is no doubt doubt in
it there is no doubt that it is from
Allah and it is a
guidance for those who are those
righteous the
dutiful who are the Righteous who are
the dutiful as defined by Allah he
says those who believe in the
Unseen those who believe in the Unseen
that's what our faith is based
on that we understand Allah is Al he is
the all
wise Allah is Al the all
knowing his knowledge encompasses
everything and everything that
exists is a derivative of his knowledge
subhanahu wa taala
however this does not mean that
everything we hear in the Quran we read
everything in the Sunnah everything that
occurred everything that happened
everything in
the every action and every statement is
understood by every single person the
Muslim body as a
whole yes we understand all of the Quran
and Sunnah specifically
individually many of us will die not
knowing or understanding aspects of the
Quran aspects of the
Sunnah but this should not hinder us
from
adhering because understanding is not a
condition of adherence understanding is
a condition a prerequisite of knowledge
as we've mentioned if I don't
particularly understand something it
doesn't make it untrue and it doesn't
make it any less
valuable and
so why do I say this oftentimes
people
many of us as Muslims when we hear a
Hadith when we hear a narration when we
hear a verse of the
Quran do this or do not do
this or believe in
this we start to ask questions and go
too far for our individual
level knowledge about these types of
things the wisdom behind things this is
something that comes with years of study
years of wisdom years of knowledge and
research this is not something that is
allotted to everyone if that were the
case everyone would be a scholar of
Islam and it's almost as if if I don't
understand this particular thing then
I'm I'm kind of suspicious of it
especially if it's in the Hadith of the
prophet sallu alai wasallam because in
most Muslims minds or many I shouldn't
say most but many Muslims Minds today in
this day and age because of the amount
of propaganda that has been pedal to us
from
outside our own
scholarship
we feel a disconnect with the Sunnah we
feel a kind of uncertainty about the
narrations of the Prophet sallallah alai
wasam and this is not something that
Scholars ever have trouble with the
true Scholars of
Islam they understand the workings of
narration the science of Hadith and that
Hadith is affirmed and preserved in the
exact same way that the Quran is
affirmed and preserved it's the same way
and so differentiating between the Quran
and Sunnah in Authority is very
problematic we don't differentiate
between the commands of Allah and the
commands of his Prophet we don't
differentiate between the Quran and the
Sunnah both of them are Revelation from
Allah subhanahu wa taala which are to
be
un which are to be adhered to
unconditionally
right the prophet S.I wasam warned us of
this and he
[Silence]
said the prophet sallallah
said anything I prohibit you just stay
away from it and anything that I command
you do it as much as you can fulfill it
to the best of your
abilities for indeed those who have came
before you in the previous Nations what
what marked their
demise
was that they were too questioning of
their
prophets and they were too disobedient
to their prophets and
Messengers this is this is a
problem there's a difference between
asking because I want to understand and
asking because I'm
suspicious especially when it comes to
the narrations of bukari and
Muslim these are agreed upon
amongst
1,300 years worth of
scholarship of Islamic scholars millions
of the most brightest minds and most
trustworthy Hearts have preserved these
two books Millions this is not a
question of nobody really asked this
question before and I think I found
something these books have been
thoroughly every listen every single
letter letter
inl has been scrutinized and
exhaustively researched letter every
single
letter and these books have
been no have met no less scrutiny
than that of the book of Allah subhanahu
waala so when we discuss the Miracles of
the Prophet sallallah alai wasallam any
one of these is sufficient
when put into context any one of these
is sufficient for us to believe in Allah
in the last day as a matter of fact to
dismiss the prophet
Muhammad's
messengership to dismiss his
prophethood is to cause more questions
than to do answers if we were to say
hypothetically you know those who posed
the argument that he was not really a
prop of
Allah this causes much more qu this
makes us have many more questions than
we do answers this causes a lot of
trouble because you have to explain all
of this away false prophets do not have
billions of people follow
them for a for a millennium a millennia
and a half this is Millennium and a half
this is not this is not the works of a
man from the
desert an illiterate man from the desert
this is revelation from Allah subhanahu
waala We are continuing in the chapters
regarding his miracles another of his
miracles was when he
commanded he said go in pursuit of a
woman that you will find at
the area or the garden of it's an
area between Mecca and Medina you will
find her
there you will find there a woman and
she has a letter bring it to
me and so they went immediately they
reached there and indeed they found this
woman there she was a non-muslim woman
on her way to
Mecca
and
commanded her to produce the letter that
she
had it was a message a letter meaning
just a
message and this message had in it it
was a message that was sent by someone
in Medina informing the people of Mecca
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam planned to come and for the
conquest of Mecca at a particular time
was during Ramadan
this was a problem because most of
warfare is surprise and Ambush this is
how War
works and most of the strategy of the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
Warfare to the extent that it could be
had to be that of surprise because this
saves lives this preserves
life the more that a person has the
element of surprise
over his
enemy this is safer for both
sides and
so one of the companions had sent this
letter for a reason which we will
discuss
inshallah and so she claimed that she
didn't have it
and said you will produce it or we will
find it we'll strip you until we find it
because the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam told us of it and so she
produced it from locks in her
[Silence]
hair
Ramadan
[Silence]
Al
sh
[Silence]
mecah
for
[Silence]
the
subh
[Silence]
for
this was an issue that
occurred in the time around the conquest
of Mecca that the prophet sallallah alai
wasallam was planning for the conquest
of
Mecca for
Ramadan in the sixth year or seventh
year after
hij
and was a companion of the Prophet
sallam who was at the Battle of bad so
he's one of the most Elite and most
esteemed of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasall 's companions he was not
native from Mecca he was not a a mecan
native but he had wealth he had family
members there
Etc and so he feared that if something
happened to where the Muslims were
unable to swiftly con conquer
Mecca if things got really messy his
wealth
is you know and also his businesses and
also his family members would be
unsafe right you could
imagine when you go to when when they
would go to conquer a
city there's a lot of things that happen
when a city is under
siege there is famine the people of
the city might start to rebel by taking
hostages of the it's very messy it can
become very messy and so he wanted to
send this letter not informing them too
much just informing that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam has taken the
decision to come and for the conquest of
Mecca this way he'd have done them a
favor and by that favor they would spare
his his wealth there they would spare
his family members
there so this is not a religious issue
in that sense he didn't do this because
he wanted to see Islam fail he didn't do
this because he wanted to see polytheism
Prevail he didn't do this out of love
for the enemies of the Prophet sallallah
alai wasam or hatred for his companions
he did
this his you know his he he found
weakness in himself and he gave into
this urge to try to protect some of
his family members this is what drove
him to doing
this and so as this letter was sent it
was sent with a woman on her way to
Mecca and the prophet sallallah alaihi
wasallam was informed of this so he sent
three of the
Companions and he said you're going to
and this is a prophecy obviously you are
going to find this woman by the time you
catch up to her she will be at which is
a kind of a rest area that is used for
those traveling between Mecca and
Medina and she has this letter bring it
back to me and so when they found her
there where the Prophet sallallah alaih
wasallam told them they found this
woman and they demanded this letter she
said I don't I don't have anything check
look
everywhere and
so said the messenger of
Allah was not
incorrect he was not false his statement
he told us this you're going to produce
this letter or we're going to strip you
until we find it and so she had it
hidden in her hair in the locks of her
hair when they brought it back to the
prophet Sall
Al it was from one of his esteemed
Companions and so this is an act of
treason this is an act Act of treason
and this is could have spelled
disaster for the conquest of Mecca if
they would have known this and the
reason that the conquest of Mecca was
happening was
because the mushin the polytheus of
Mecca they had gone back on their treaty
with the prophet
Sall they had a treaty at
hudia and this treaty was more than
generous
to the
mush it was more than fair it was it was
actually quite
one-sided meaning that the
mushin they had come to these terms that
looked very
one-sided for instance anyone who
becomes Muslim in Mecca and leaves we
return him to
you but anyone who leaves us to go back
to Mecca and leave to rejoin your
forces against us we will allow him to
go this is very one-sided more than
generous and in spite of that they still
broke their word and violated this
treaty violation of treaties is an act
of
War it's killing a
messenger of you know a king or you
you if you harm The Messengers that come
to you to and fro between this is an act
of
war and this wasn't the only thing that
they did but they broke their end of
this treaty and
so it was clear and they did this
knowingly which meant that they meant
to break this treaty and go to war
with the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasall and his
companions and so the conquest of Mecca
was devised and it was planned for and
it was to be sudden why so that they are
not able to have time to close the
city's Gates and prepare themselves for
Siege which is this could have lasted
you know
months and could have spelled disaster
for the conquest of Mecca and for the
people in Mecca and also many of the
Muslims that are still in Mecca there's
a lot of Muslims in
Mecca and if something this were
to happen the polytheist in Mecca would
turn against
them and so it was a priority to the
prophet sallai wasam that he not allow
this message to reach
Mecca so he asked what what caused you
to do this what made you do this and he
said oh messenger of Allah it is not
love
for idolatry nor hatred for Islam rather
and he told him the reason and so the
prophet sallam forgave him for
[Silence]
that
B
[Silence]
wasam
for
[Silence]
another Miracle of the Prophet
sallallah alai wasallam was an incident
that happened
[Silence]
with
subh
[Silence]
for
he says that
aan came at night Abu Hur was serving
guard Duty over
the the
treasury and someone came at night and
tried to steal so Abu Hur he caught him
in the
act
and Abu was going to take him to the
prophet sallallah alaih wasallam to be
punished and he complained to him he
said you know I'm I I'm so poor I'm so
hungry I have kids etc etc and so he let
him
go and the prophet sallallah alai wasam
saw Abu the next day and he asked him
about it and he
said that person that you meant met is a
Shan was actually one of the Devils of
the Gin kind that had taken that form
and come to you and he will come back
and the next night he returned again
and again he gave this big long Sab
story
and abuur let him
go and on the third night he came back
and Abu Hur was determined that this
time this is your last strike you are
going to the prophet sallallah alai
wasam and so at this point he saw that
the sa story wasn't working anymore so
he said if you let me go I will teach
you something
something and it is
regarding the 255th verse
of and this shows
how important knowledge is to the
companions especially when it has to do
with the
Quran you might think well how does he
know
this he knows this because he is
aan and what he's going to inform us is
something that the experience
with he said if you
recite before you go to
sleep no devil will be able to come
close to you until morning time how does
he know this from
experience and so he told the prophet
sallai wasam of this and the prophet
Sall confirmed this he
said he said this time time he was
telling the truth but this is this
person is a liar but this he was
correcting and
so the prophet sallallah wasam informed
him of what was to happen the next day
and the day after that of the reality of
this
person just to stop here for a second at
narration many of us know this narration
many of us take this as an
Evidence
that we should study everywhere we
should seek knowledge with everyone we
should learn from anyone because here
Abu is taking Knowledge
from and this is incorrect of course
because there's a difference
between hearing
something from a source and verifying it
it's a difference between that and
actively going to aan to seek knowledge
from him AB didn't seek out aan to ask
him is a different
[Silence]
thing
mus
[Silence]
for
allb
ill